président vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas
par le djing ah oui le bouveret pas le
sait tout le monde le sait une touche
pendant le giga bien c'est l'interview
nul oui vous préférez steyn ou hitler ni
l'un ni l'autre je déteste stalinisme et
l'hitlérisme et le fascisme c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut combattre toute
sa vie préféré à l'indolence jean paul
belmondo avait coûté jolie pas devant
son fils j'adore a down de long même si
on pense pas tout à fait la même chose
et la première fois que j'ai vu c'était
pour les 10 ans tf1 75 à la tour eiffel
c'est mourousi qui me l'a présenté mais
tomber dans les bras et il m'a dit tu
sais je t'aime bien
et depuis on est devenus amis d'abord
oui et ont tellement d'eau je le connais
mais j'ai pas les mêmes bien qu'avec
alain delon oui il a des gens qui aiment
votre père ah oui heureusement bien vous
partez trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial président oui vous préféré
partir avec etienne mougeotte marc
tessier patron de france télévisions où
pierre lescure sophie marceau vous
croisez un extraterrestre amateurs de
leur acheter des cigarettes extra
terrestre si vous êtes qui vous et vous
connais évidemment vous ne répondez quoi
je suis un mais bourges
ah oui il suffit de penser que les
extraterrestres je n'ai passé qu'une
importance lui dit pas je suis un
terrien de façon il passe son chemin et
moi le mien et je suis un humain chez
intérieurs uche hervé bourmaud les bras
qui vous êtes fuir les boukakes accord
bien avec katia ça c'est un email de jim
pour envoyer des emails pour des
questions ça s'est compliqué avec quel
pays la france est la plus grande
frontière sait rien si tu étais vache
qui rit avec la belgique mais c'est quoi
exactement
la série à le brésil bravo à cause de la
guyane
tout à fait vous voyez qu'une si vous
étiez en vente dans un sex-shop seriez
quoi je ne crois que je ne serai jamais
en vendant un seul cheval à la baisse
parce que je ne suis pas suffisamment
attire
quel est le sport le plus combo le
football américain
aulas ben voilà amérique vous ne vous
défendez plus les américains
mon équipe de football américain
alors expliquez vous pourrez c'est bien
alors assis très sexy comme sport les
uniformes sont fantastiques ben c'est
devenu un petit peu plus que maintenant
parce qu'il ya trop de publicité et elle
vient 30 ans c'était quelque chose
d'ordinaire le c'est comme le sport ou
le foot ici en europe des combien sa
mise en hyper son mystère
alors si vous deviez partir sur une île
déserte ou partiriez avec un mec très
beau une fille très laide mélanine unis
monde bat en effet pas attiré par les
hommes et je n'ai pas les filles moches
mais non nous on en a une qui s'appelle
nina si tu nous regardes nina inadi moi
chaque fois qu'un acteur ou quelqu'un
qui veut partir avec une fille mais je
suis d'accord
voilà ce que samuel le bihan par exemple
il disait moi je préfère partir avec une
fille mais je suis d'accord elle quand
elle a vu samuel le bihan va bien si
vous deviez mourir présidence de
l'accident d'avion vous préféreriez que
ce soit air france darrigues légifère ça
mais c'est strictement égal si je dois
mourir peu importe la compagnie l'état
nationaliste vous préfériez mourir comme
otis redding dans un crash d'avion comme
john lennon d'un d'un shot comme bones
scott le chanteur des 6-10 6 étouffé
dans son vomi ou comme janis joplin qui
est morte d'une overdose nourrir le
cerveau mine en sortant la tour d'argent
non il ya longtemps que je vais plus à
la tour d'argent c'est ta mère bordel
le canard au sang était pas mal mais
c'est plus ce que c'était un variety's
salon chichiteux est-ce que vous
accordez plus de circonstances
atténuantes à vieux qui se tape des
jeunes où un jeune qui tapent sur des
vieux pros je n'aime pas les jeunes qui
tapent sur des vieux bois je préfère un
vieux qui se tape une jeune si elle est
consentante et d'avoir
voilà vient alors la ccxr il y en a tous
les deux bloqués dans un chalet oui la 4
mètres de neige
oui je meurs de faim oui et pour pas
mourir de faim vous me manger vous
commencez par quoi réside en je vais
vous le dire par l'oreille aux parce que
quand je vais au restaurant quelques
fois j'adore manger les oreilles de
cochon
j'ai pas ajouté et parce que le placer
les oreilles et la queue de cochon et ça
fait attention au président qu'est ce
que fait le plus plaisir maintenant oui
moi de vivre c'est un bonheur formidable
d'être libres d'être aujourd'hui
d'un autre côté j'étais dans le xvème
oui où il ya des tours etc
j'avais un but au splendid j'avais de
vue sur les lots sur tout paris et puis
un poème d'apollinaire sur le pont
mirabeau
maintenant je suis dans 9e du côté de la
rue montmartre est formidable c'est
plein de riches trop il ya une vie à
quoi comme banny nationaux moi j'ai pas
de bagnole plonge en avait eu une avoir
aimé car sinon et mes collègues m'ont
offert en partant une carte orange ou
bleu mais trop sur ses amours je ne vois
pas je connais j'ai pris le métro dans
mon enfance dans ma jeunesse beaucoup
c'est vrai disons le ce a fait une
vingtaine d'années que j'ai pris le
métro via pas de visuel et que j'ai
toujours été à des postes de
responsabilités qu'une voiture et
chauffeur mais je reprends le métro avec
un plaisir formidable peux même vous
dire que l'autre jour j'étais à une
réunion du quai d'orsay et j'ai pris le
métro à à l'assemblée nationale
direction porte de la chapelle
c'est là où j'ai changé j'ai pris
créteil pour descendre un grand
boulevard y aller
la salle
merci parce qu'il dit pas c'est qu'il a
pris europ assistance pourtant ça c'est
la petite histoire